[Música]
y
bienvenidos al segmento kobe 19 la
semana en américa el espacio de france
24 en que hacemos un resumen de las
noticias más destacadas que tienen
relación con la pandemia de kobe 19 a
continuación les presento algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar en el segmento
de hoy hablaremos del fin del uso de las
mascarillas en varios países esta semana
fue eeuu el último en anunciarlo en
medio de una gran controversia allí fue
levantado el mandato del uso de las
mascarillas otros países de la región
como por ejemplo paraguay también han
optado por esta medida veremos lo que
implica y veremos en detalle también la
situación epidemiológica en países como
perú y bolivia
en el primero avanza rápidamente la
vacunación al tiempo que también
eliminaron el uso de las mascarillas en
unas zonas específicas del país de otra
parte en bolivia conoceremos los planes
del gobierno para sortear la crisis
económica que afecta a varios sectores
de ese país debido a la pandemia y en
nuestra habitual consulta con el doctor
pérez nuestro asesor científico
hablaremos sobre lo que nos ha enseñado
y 19 y los preparados que estamos para
poder enfrentar una nueva pandemia en el
futuro también hablaremos de varios
adelantos científicos y médicos que
están relacionados con las secuelas del
joven 19 y también algunos tratamientos
precisamente para evitar este virus pues
comenzamos este segmento y lo hacemos
entonces actualizando algunas cifras y
datos importantes
veamos cifras de contagios y de
fallecidos en los últimos 28 días en
algunos países del cono sur vamos a
comenzar en argentina allí en los
últimos 28 días han reportado más de 39
mil 600 casos y más de 500 personas han
fallecido debido al cove' 19 en el
vecino país chile los casos en los
últimos 28 días se cuentan por encima de
los 112 mil y los fallecidos son más de
1100 pasemos ahora a la república
oriental del uruguay allí recientemente
reportaron más de 14.600 personas
contagiadas 50 personas fallecieron por
kobe 19 en paraguay hay que reportar un
poco más de mil casos nuevos y los
fallecidos ya superan los 170 en los
últimos 28 días vamos a finalizar esta
ronda en brasil en donde en los últimos
28 días ya han contabilizado más de
500.000 casos y más de 4.100 personas
han fallecido en los últimos 28 días
y para profundizar en lo que ha ocurrido
en estos dos últimos meses en torno a la
pandemia de kobe 19 y los avances que
hay a lo largo de los últimos días está
con nosotros el doctor pérez para
acompañarnos aquí en nuestra habitual
consulta para conversar con él y
adelantar entonces algunos temas que
tenemos en la agenda doctor como siempre
un gusto tenerlo aquí en el programa
'tengo en muchos temas para consultarle
en este momento doctor y comienzo por
preguntarle lo que nos deja la pandemia
hasta el momento estamos preparados para
afrontar una nueva pandemia en el futuro
próximo que lecciones nos deja hasta
hasta el momento esta emergencia
sanitaria global que todavía sigue en
marcha
es una pregunta compleja porque tenemos
muchas incertidumbres creo que hay algo
que hemos podido ganar como humanidad
que es la ciencia en la respuesta que
hubo con una vacuna en una forma muy
rápida además de es una comunidad
científica
respondió al reto que era una pandemia
pero por otro lado tenemos
complicaciones como la asimetría asociar
la disminución de los recursos
la falta de liderazgo de los organismos
multilaterales y en fin otro tipo de
circunstancias que no pasan por la parte
médica
creo que una próxima pandemia es mucho
más cercana que lo que pasó cien años
antes porque nosotros hemos tenido una
pérdida de control sobre el medio
ambiente no estamos controlando y
monitorizando efectivamente los virus
como hemos estado haciendo
constantemente y debemos aprender de
este tiempo que hicimos bien para poder
enfrentar las pantallas pero todavía
estamos en la incertidumbre porque
estamos terminando de entender lo que
vivimos para qué tengamos mejores
herramientas para intentarlo el futuro
doctor es una pregunta difícil de
responder sé que a lo largo de los
diferentes programas le he consultado
sobre este tema y poco a poco hemos
empezado a armar ese rompecabezas de
todas las lecciones que nos deja esta
pandemia kobe 19 no solamente en el área
médica en el área científica sino a
nivel social económico político son
múltiples los aspectos en los que nos ha
afectado también le he preguntado en
reiteradas ocasiones sobre su opinión
por las decisiones que están tomando
algunos gobiernos en torno al uso de la
mascarilla algunos países ya se muestran
muy confiados con la baja tasa de
contagio que están presentando ya han
comenzado a levantar esta restricción
del uso de las mascarillas algunos
mantienen algunas restricciones como
podemos seguir cuidando nos qué ventajas
trae el uso de la mascarilla que nos
hicieron en ese momento
usarla como el arma básica para combatir
el cob y 19 que ahora no la necesitamos
pero cómo podemos seguir luchando contra
el virus para defendernos
hay un momento importante lo primero es
que cuando se coloca la mascarilla pues
estábamos en esa zona alta
transmisibilidad ya la evidencia
científica muestra que el espacio
exterior es realmente pues la
transmisibilidad es muy poca y por eso
se puede servir libremente sin
mascarillas ahora bien es sobre los
espacios cerrados yo creo que hay dos
cosas importantes cuando una persona
tiene síntomas respiratorios debe
aislarse y usar una mascarilla yo creo
que eso no va a pasar eso se tiene que
continuar y eso va a continuar en el
tiempo lo segundo es que las mascarillas
debemos hacer correctamente nosotros lo
que vemos es que mucha gente lo uso que
lo usa inadecuadamente y el usar las
carillas sin lavado de mano realmente no
es eficiente entonces muchas veces estas
mascarillas más usadas que se manipulan
inadecuadamente que andando en el cuello
que no cubren y no se usan correctamente
realmente vuelve más bien a los vectores
que realmente en un control yo creo que
la mascarilla se va a tener que ir
descargando pausadamente
una forma la mascarilla sea dejar de
usar paulatinamente no de un solo
momento a otro pero si va a seguir en
personas que tengan síntomas
respiratorios y eso debemos haberlo
aprendido que hemos aprendido también en
los últimos 100 años y por otro lado en
la higiene de manos santiago la higiene
es parte fundamental para controlar las
infecciones respiratorias y nosotros
debemos preservar esa lección aprendida
de la pandemia para que siga en la
higiene como un estandarte en nuestro
comportamiento social ante estas
enfermedades yo creo que la mascarilla
en situación de infección respiratoria y
el uso adecuado y contar constante las
manos va a perpetuarse en el tiempo y
humanas ya se dr rápidamente le pregunto
por un concepto que introduce usted en
su respuesta que es la baja
transmisibilidad
entre que rangos se puede considerar que
hay una baja transmisibilidad de un
virus en este caso el coronavirus
hay un concepto que se llama positividad
que es el número de pruebas que se
realizan y cuántas de ellas salen
positivas en general cuando están por
encima del 10% uno habla de una
transmisibilidad alta cuando está por
debajo del 10% más controlada y en este
momento en algunas regiones del mundo
está por debajo del 1% ese es uno de los
criterios hay otro criterio que se
llaman un número estadístico que se
llaman número r que es la capacidad que
tiene una persona para enfermar a otras
cuando ese ere está menos de uno que uno
considera que la infección está
controlada y que la positividad de la
práctica baja transmisibilidad son más
los criterios que uno tiene en cuenta
para hablar de esos conceptos de
restricción de la de la transmisión del
virus pero eso no quiere que se haya
eliminado ni que deje de ser grave las
personas no vacunadas las personas que
han perdido la inmunidad las personas
inmunosuprimidas o que no han recibido
refuerzos siguen siendo susceptibles y
al pesar de haber una onda planificarse
pueden enfermar y se pueden enfermar
gravemente lo que pasa es que hacer una
población mucho más pequeña que lo que
estaba sucediendo
anteriores doctor también le pregunto
por otro concepto que ha sonado mucho a
lo largo de esta semana debido a que
varios países han declarado el fin de la
emergencia sanitaria y lo hacen cuando
tienen baja transmisión comunitaria esto
está ligado con este concepto que nos
acaba de explicar o son dos conceptos
completamente diferentes no es el mismo
concepto la transmisión comunitaria es
el número de enfermos que hay en cierta
población y esta declaración de
emergencia es para apropiar recursos
tomar medidas excepcionales para control
poblacional tomar algunas medidas y
decisiones políticas
para poder enfrentar la pandemia
paulatinamente al disminuir esta
transmisión comunitaria se toman este
tipo de medidas que ya no son tan
necesarias como lo que sucedía hace dos
años plan de embargo es la política que
debía permanecer es la de la pedagogía
la de mantener la higiene y de hacer esa
etiqueta respiratoria que es mantener un
tapabocas cuando una persona tenga
síntomas respiratorios doctor cada
semana hablamos de algunos de los
síntomas que deja el kobe largo en esta
oportunidad quiero por los daños
cardiovasculares que dicen las
investigaciones que hay en curso sobre
este tema y que han notado ustedes en la
comunidad médica y científica en torno a
los daños a nivel de corazón en
pacientes que ya sufrieron cobit
si eso son vídeos que como hemos hablado
en esta semana no deja de sorprendernos
hablamos de compromisos neurológicos
pulmonares
oftalmológicos en el sistema de los
órganos de los sentidos en el corazón es
muy especial porque el virus afecta
directamente el corazón donde sucede la
parte severa de la enfermedad y hay
complicaciones de tipo inflamatorio que
llamamos pericarditis miocarditis que es
esa inflamación del corazón que puede
dejar secuelas funcionales a mediano
plazo
hemos encontrado también el aumento de
las enfermedades coronarias de los
eventos vasculares en personas que han
sufrido coke y realmente también el uso
de fármacos como fue el uso de la hidro
si cloroquina en el uso de los microbios
que son un tipo de antibióticos como la
setravi china que se usó mucho que
producen afectación cardiaca también en
personas con lesión cardiaca y kobe se
sumaron para hacer este daño cardiaco el
corazón es algo que debemos evaluar en
personas que han tenido un coach severo
es recomendable hacerse un chequeo
cardiovascular porque hemos encontrado
daños no cárnicos
un buen examen físico y tomando en las
medidas se pueden controlar pero es
necesario consultar al médico para hacer
eso son bastante frecuentes santiago
doctor muchas gracias por aclarar estos
temas todas estas incógnitas que
teníamos en nuestra agenda para nuestra
consulta muchas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros como siempre un gustazo a
continuación les presento el número de
dosis de refuerzo por cada 100
habitantes en una serie de países al
azar de nuestro continente vamos a
comenzar en el extremo norte comencemos
en canadá allí ya han sido inoculadas 48
57 dosis por cada 100 habitantes una
proporción bastante alta una de las más
altas del continente en panamá por
ejemplo ya llegan hasta el 34 02 dosis
por cada 100 habitantes en colombia las
relaciones de 21 73 dosis por cada 100
habitantes su vecino brasil alcanza el
40 22 dosis por cada 100 habitantes
estamos hablando de dosis de refuerzo y
terminamos en argentina en donde han
sido inoculadas
4405 dosis de refuerzo por cada en
habitantes
y nos vamos entonces ahora hasta perú en
donde hubo varias noticias para destacar
a lo largo de esta semana vamos a lima
allí se encuentra francisco zacarías
para contarnos las novedades que hubo
hola francisco gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa y las
autoridades peruanas estiman que para el
mes de julio en pleno invierno austral
lleguen ya al 80 por ciento de la
población vacunada con dosis de refuerzo
cuál es la estrategia que tienen allí
las autoridades para alcanzar esa cifra
hola santiago las autoridades sanitarias
consideran que en alrededor de tres
meses pero alcanzará el 80 por ciento de
la población vacunada con las tres dosis
los funcionarios sustenta en la
proyección porque afirman que están
inmunizando a un promedio de 40.000 a
50.000 personas por día y aseguran que
la meta se podría alcanzar en tiempo más
corto si es que los peruanos asumieron
el compromiso de darle prioridad a la
vacunación porque señalan que cuentan
con suficientes dosis de vacunas insumos
y brigadas de inmunización por eso el
ministerio de salud de este país
ejecutará más acciones para impulsar la
inoculación casa por casa y en puntos
estratégicos pero tiene actualmente una
cobertura cercana al 52 por ciento de
personas con las 3 dosis sin embargo las
autoridades reconocen que existe una
brecha grande de niños de 5 a 11 años
que no han recibido su segunda dosis y
por eso articularán tareas con el sector
educación para vacunar a los menores en
los colegios francisco leyendo varios
reportes de medios allí en perú el
ministerio de salud advirtió sobre un
posible rebrote
de contagios y también de fallecidos de
la sub variante ve a punto 2 que es una
variante de una sub variante de la
variante omicron para el mes de octubre
que medidas preventivas entonces están
tomando allí en perú de cara a estos
meses que hay hasta llegar a ese posible
pico en el mes de octubre
jorge lópez ministro de salud de este
país ha alertado que las proyecciones
son el preludio de una posible cuarta
ola de coronavirus en perú las
autoridades sanitarias detectaron la
existencia de 35 casos era su variante
ve a 12 o micro en un período de dos
meses cuando precisamente la cantidad de
contagios de kobe 19 registraron un
drástico descenso en esta nación andina
25 personas infectadas son de lima y las
demás provienen de otras regiones del
perú el análisis de los científicos
locales presenta un escenario delicado
para el mes de octubre con altas
probabilidades de enfermos y fallecidos
y tal como señalan los expertos una
nueva cepa podría variar las
proyecciones por eso el instituto
nacional de salud ejecuta constantes
análisis genómicos del sars cop 2 en el
país el temor de las autoridades se
centra en las variantes xd xd y xf que
se reproducen rápidamente pero es el
momento no han llegado al perú francisco
también destacado esta semana se anunció
allí en perú de el retiro del uso de la
mascarilla en lugares públicos en unos
sitios muy puntuales del país
principalmente en el área metropolitana
de lima que novedades al respecto
esa es una buena noticia para los
peruanos a partir del primero de mayo ya
no es obligatorio el uso de mascarillas
esto era una exigencia ciudadana y las
autoridades ordenaron la flexibilización
de restricciones para lugares públicos
de lima callao ica ancash pero en
espacios cerrados se continuará
exigiendo su uso así como la obligación
de presentar el carnet de vacunación con
las tres dosis otras regiones del país
que superen el 80 por ciento de
inmunización podrían ingresar a esta
nueva disposición cuando alcancen la
meta pero la defensoría del pueblo
rechaza la ordenanza porque considera
que incrementaría los contagios del cob
y 19 y sus variantes el organismo
advierte que la población en su
totalidad aún no cuenta con la tercera
dosis y precisa que en perú los espacios
abiertos son lugares donde las personas
se aglomeran y rompen los protocolos
sanitarios
la defensoría por eso exige al gobierno
de pedro casi o evitar decisiones que
motiven el descuido ciudadano ante la
pandemia muchas gracias francisco por
este completo reporte desde la ciudad de
lima hablamos ahora de eeuu y ya no es
obligatorio utilizar mascarilla en los
medios de transporte público así como
dentro de los aeropuertos las estaciones
de trenes y de autobuses la medida fue
dictada por una jueza federal y no es
del agrado de la administración del
presidente baten por lo que apelará en
esta medida en una corte un poco más
conservadora rafael pérez nos cuenta más
fin del uso obligatorio de mascarillas
en el transporte público estadounidense
la jueza federal caitlin clean vall
consideró que el mandato de uso de
tapabocas por parte del centro para el
control y prevención de enfermedades cdc
excedía su autoridad legal las
reacciones no se hicieron esperar es
mucho menos estresante no tener que
preocuparme por tener una máscara
arrojado para volver no tengo ningún
problema con eso lo uso para mi
beneficio para mi salud por lo que no
tengo ningún problema con el mandato de
la máscara
sin embargo otros tienen una visión más
profunda sobre el tema y creo que será
un tema partidista para siempre solo
porque se trata de los cuerpos de las
personas y su salud mental y bienestar
así que creo que variará a la persona a
persona el dictamen de la jueza se dio a
conocer cuando el gobierno extendía al
menos dos semanas el uso del implemento
sanitario en medio de un rebrote causado
por la sub variante ba2 la reacción
oficial de la casa blanca llegó de la
mano de su secretaria de prensa
los cds se recomendaron continuar la
orden por un tiempo adicional dos
semanas para poder evaluar las
investigaciones y cumplir con su
responsabilidad de proteger al pueblo
estadounidense así que obviamente esto
es una decisión decepcionante el
presidente validen se pronunció al
respecto sin mediar muchas palabras con
los periodistas
las personas deberían seguir utilizando
máscaras en los aviones eso depende de
ellos el mismo día el departamento de
justicia anunció que apelaría el fallo
judicial en el undécimo circuito de
mayoría conservadora con el objetivo de
restaurar la medida
habiendo entendido ya toda esta
controversia y las discrepancias entre
el poder judicial del gobierno del
presidente baten vamos a conocer más
detalles de lo que está sucediendo en
eeuu saludamos entonces santo nivel si
en la ciudad de miami para conocer el
balance de esta primera semana sin el
uso obligatorio de la mascarilla y en
eeuu
pues si santiago como apuntaba es a
principios de esta semana una jueza de
florida revocó la orden federal de usar
mascarillas en las principales redes de
transporte como aeropuertos aviones
trenes o autobuses la magistrada que por
cierto fue nominada por el ex presidente
de donald trump para ocupar un puesto en
la corte de distrito alegó que los
centros para el control y prevención de
enfermedades los cdc
se habían excedido en su autoridad para
imponer su mandato de mascarillas de
hecho la casa blanca había excedido esta
medida durante dos semanas más hasta el
3 de mayo por temor a un aumento de
casos por la nueva variante de el
coronavirus pero en general muchos en
eeuu han celebrado que se eliminará esta
orden obligatoria del tapabocas y dicen
que llevar o no mascarilla debería ser
una decisión personal y no algo que
estuviera supeditado a la legalidad el
presidente joe biden ya ha avanzado que
no se descarta apelar esta decisión
judicial dependiendo de lo que digan los
cdc sobre esta cuestión los funcionarios
sanitarios de eeuu recuerdan que la
pandemia no ha terminado y siguen
recomendando que la gente lleve
mascarillas
cerrados aunque ahora ya no pueden
obligar a ellos anthony quiero que
hagamos balance de las cifras porque
esta semana anunciaron algunas de ellas
más de novecientas mil personas han
fallecido en eeuu por kobe 19 y 80 como
72 millones de casos activos en este
país que más dicen las autoridades
si el gobierno de eeuu se aferra a esa
cifra de casi un millón de muertes por
coronavirus para insistir en que la
crisis sanitaria no ha terminado a pesar
de que los datos de muertes y
hospitalizaciones han bajado actualmente
en el país los máximos responsables
sanitarios del gobierno norteamericano
aseguran que la población está en una
mejor posición ahora que hace dos años
principalmente porque se cuentan con
vacunas y tratamientos para hacer frente
al mortal virus pese a eso el mensaje
sigue siendo el mismo no hay que bajar
la guardia se han de seguir tomando
precauciones y se han de impulsar
estrategias comunes para frenar los
contagios especialmente entre las
personas con condiciones médicas
pre-existentes y aquellas personas que
no se han vacunado hay que recordar que
poco más de la mitad de la población de
eeuu un 65% se ha inoculado a pesar de
las campañas del gobierno para promover
la vacunación entre sus ciudadanos con
todo confían en que las medidas
implementadas hasta ahora sean efectivas
para evitar nuevos brotes de contagios
aseguran que ahora a están mucho mejor
preparados para en caso de que hubiera
una nueva ola de casos positivos además
la posibilidad de cierre aquí casi se
descarta por completo
antonio eeuu anunció que va a participar
en esa cumbre mundial de kobe 19 que
está prevista para el mes de mayo esta
cumbre que fin tiene quienes participan
y cuál es el fin de ella
si el próximo 12 de mayo se celebrará la
segunda cumbre mundial sobre la comida
que será de nuevo virtual y analizará el
estado de la pandemia y cómo afrontar
futuras amenazas sanitarias se anunció a
través de un comunicado suscrito por los
países del g20 del g7 también la
comunidad del caribe y la unión africana
pero es eeuu la nación que está
liderando el encuentro que tiene como
objetivo poner sobre la mesa soluciones
para vacunar al mundo también salvar
vidas ahora y también construir una
mejor seguridad sanitaria para todos y
para todo el mundo en la cumbre la
cumbre se organizará en torno a los
compromisos acordados en la primera
reunión que tuvo lugar en septiembre de
2021 entre los que está el hecho de
facilitar y desarrollar tests y
tratamientos y también dirigirse a las
poblaciones más vulnerables con todo
también se busca financiación para
afrontar las nuevas amenazas y las
pandemias entre todos los países que
participen en esta cumbre antonio y
gracias por este reporte desde la ciudad
de miami en el sur del estado de la
florida y como parte de la normalización
de las actividades algunos países han
puesto fin al estado de emergencia lo
que les permitió determinar en su
momento las leyes para combatir la
pandemia de kobe 19 había el escenario
es distinto veamos entonces cuáles son
los países de la región que ya han
derogado esta medida son pocos brasil
uruguay y paraguay méxico lo hemos
puesto un poco más separado porque se
espera que lo haga en los próximos días
ya lo han debatido allí lo han
conversado y ha sido comentado en los
medios de comunicación
después de más de dos años de medidas
especiales el ministerio de salud
pública de brasil derogó el estado de
emergencia establecido por la pandemia
de coronavirus lo que les estamos
comentando anteriormente la medida
respaldada por el descenso en el número
de casos y también la disminución de la
letalidad entre los ciudadanos
rafael pérez nos cuenta más
donde la emergencia sanitaria en basil
ministerio de salud quien tenga
prerrogativa el ministerio de salud es
quien tiene la prerrogativa legal de
establecer la duración de una emergencia
de salud pública de importancia nacional
nacional e intente combatir los padres
ser estas áreas técnica entiende con
base en el parecer de las áreas técnicas
que nosotros no tenemos más en brasil
una emergencia de salud pública e
importancia nacional por tras ser la
zona o al decir del ministro de salud
del gigante suramericano el
derrocamiento no significa el término de
la pandemia porque a cofide innova cabo
en neiva capa porque el coi no acabó ni
va a acabar por lo menos en una fecha
próxima y nosotros necesitamos convivir
con esta enfermedad y convivir con este
virus
felizmente parece que el virus se ha
atenuado ha disminuido su letalidad
20007 la letalidad el llamado estado de
emergencia en la salud pública fue
decretado en febrero del año 2020 antes
de que fuera confirmado el primer caso
en el país lo que permitió la aplicación
de ciertas medidas sanitarias que
después del fin del período especial
ogando según quiroga la anulación de la
emergencia se debe a la baja sostenida
de las infecciones y las muertes incluso
de la última ola de contagios por la
variante omicron el funcionario
garantizó además que el sistema de salud
se mantendrá en alerta y estará listo
para cualquier contingencia a pesar del
fin de la emergencia se mantendrán las
políticas públicas que según el ministro
han permitido el reforzamiento del
sistema de sanidad en brásil
recordemos que américa latina fue una de
las regiones más lentas en comenzar el
proceso de vacunación que fue disparado
y llegó a la región un poco más tarde
comparado con otros lugares del mundo
algunos países avanzaron haciendo la
tarea de manera muy rápida como chile y
uruguay otros les ha costado mucho
acceder a los biológicos veamos entonces
el listado de los países con los
porcentajes más bajos de vacunación en
américa latina' sin ser cifras del todo
malas porque algunas se aproximan casi a
la mitad de la población de los países o
un poco menos son las naciones que menos
habitantes tienen con vacuna con el
esquema completo de vacunación mejor
comencemos entonces con bolivia en donde
el 49 31% de la población tiene el
esquema completo seguimos en descenso y
nos encontramos con honduras con el 48,0
5% de la población en paraguay el
porcentaje alcanza el 47 74 por ciento
de la población le sigue surinam donde
levemente superan el 40,15 por ciento de
los habitantes y en el último lugar está
guatemala en donde el esquema completo
ha sido inoculado solamente al 33 27 por
ciento de los habitantes
y nos vamos hasta bolivia en este país
el gobierno intenta dar un impulso a
diferentes sectores productivos de esa
nación para superar la crisis económica
derivada por la pandemia del cobi 19
esto al tiempo que también disminuyen
los casos de contagio vamos a conocer
entonces los detalles con mery vaca
desde la ciudad de la paz hola mary
gracias por estar con nosotros en el
programa y quiero preguntarle entonces
por esas medidas por ese
un tema que ha desarrollado el gobierno
a lo largo de esta semana para presentar
su estrategia para hacer frente a la
crisis económica
hola qué tal santiago la crisis
económica producto de la pandemia ha
golpeado con fuerza a los bolivianos tal
es así que muchas empresas han tenido
que cerrar sus puertas y una gran
cantidad de trabajadores han quedado sin
empleo en ese contexto diferentes
gremios empresariales han pedido al
gobierno de luis arse que no apruebe un
incremento salarial por decreto sin el
consenso previo porque eso las llevaría
a la ruina en esta situación sin embargo
en bolivia existe la costumbre de que el
incremento salarial del año se anuncia
hasta el primero de mayo en homenaje al
día del trabajador y es por eso que en
estas jornadas existen intensas
negociaciones entre las autoridades del
gobierno y los personeros de la central
obrera boliviana los trabajadores han
pedido un incremento del 7 por ciento al
salario básico y del 10% al salario
mínimo que en bolivia está en 310
dólares los empresarios han rechazado
esta propuesta y han pedido que el
gobierno les invite también a dialogar
pues son ellos los que pagan los
salarios y también los impuestos sin
embargo el gobierno está haciendo este
diálogo solamente con los trabajadores y
no ha invitado hasta ahora a los
empresarios
pero hablemos de buenas noticias y
cifras positivas y eso va relacionado
con los contagios menos de 100 casos de
contagio en dos días consecutivos allí
en bolivia que más datos al respecto
así de santiago este dato ha traído
alivio y tranquilidad a la población
boliviana de hecho la atención por
ejemplo en los hospitales es
prácticamente normal y según los médicos
aquellas personas que llegan hasta las
unidades de terapia intensiva o que
finalmente fallecen en esta coyuntura es
porque no se han vacunado pero en
general las actividades en bolivia han
ido retornando a la normalidad aunque el
gobierno ha pedido que la gente no se
confíe todavía y por eso ha decidido
mantener la emergencia sanitaria pues no
se descarta que pudiera llegar una
quinta ola como ha sucedido en otras
partes del mundo pero por ahora se puede
decir que la cuarta ola está controlada
y para el cierre hagamos balance general
hablemos de fallecidos casos de contagio
personas vacunadas vacunación completa y
las restricciones cuáles se mantienen y
cuáles pueden ser levantadas en los
próximos días
bueno según datos oficiales en bolivia
se han registrado más de 900.000
personas positivas con kobe 19 durante
la pandemia y en cuanto a fallecidos
estos mismos datos señalan que son casi
22 mil personas las que han perdido la
vida por kobe 19 sin embargo existe un
estudio independiente de la universidad
privada boliviana que señala que los
muertos por covite son alrededor de
64.000 es decir el triple que los datos
oficiales en cuanto a la vacunación hay
que decir que al principio ha existido
una resistencia de ciertos grupos de la
población en contra de la inoculación
sin embargo poco a poco se ha ido
avanzando en esta materia y en la
actualidad se puede decir que el 57 por
ciento de la población ya tiene el
esquema completo es decir la primera y
la segunda dosis los especialistas
señalan que si se suma esto y además las
personas que se han enfermado en la
última ola se podría decir que bolivia
está alcanzando la inmunidad colectiva
en tanto el gobierno ha decidido como
les decía mantener la emergencia
sanitaria aunque las actividades
prácticamente han vuelto a la normalidad
por ejemplo los estudiantes ya están
asistiendo a clases presenciales existen
fiestas de todo tipo además de
conciertos y actividades deportivas con
público eso sí el gobierno sigue
pidiendo la prueba pcr en negativa para
el ingreso a territorio nacional me di
muchas gracias completísimo informes
desde la ciudad de la paz brevemente les
presentamos otras noticias destacadas de
la semana en nuestro continente
brevemente entonces les cuento que a
partir de esta semana el uso de la
mascarilla pasará a ser voluntario en el
salvador y ahora de ahora en adelante
será a discreción de los ciudadanos
quienes decidan si lo usan o no se
utilizan o no la mascarilla como método
de protección contra el jove 19 también
brevemente les cuento que con la llegada
del invierno austral y la temporada de
las lluvias en buena parte de américa
del sur la influenza reapareció en
ecuador pero con una baja intensidad las
autoridades de salud desde ya están
afinando sus planes de prevención para
evitar que en el pico de la temporada
más fría del año haya un repunte de
casos de influenza a la par que de casos
de kobe 19 y terminamos en panamá este
país en reportó sus primeras 24 horas
sin contabilizar fallecidos por kobe 19
una cifra que por supuesto satisface a
las autoridades los nuevos casos superan
los 400 el acumulado de fallecidos desde
que comenzó la pandemia es de más de 8
mil 100 casos lo que representa una
letalidad del 11 por ciento
bueno y son varios los países que les
hemos estado comentando que ya
levantaron la obligatoriedad del uso del
tapabocas algunos lo exigen en lugares
cerrados otros como lo veíamos lo han
dejado para el uso voluntario de las
personas a discreción de los ciudadanos
la lista va creciendo conforme están
pasando los días ya vemos que brasil
costa rica el salvador chile república
dominicana argentina paraguay uruguay
panamá perú méxico y eeuu en donde ya
les contábamos hubo controversia sobre
la derogación de este mandato ya no es
necesario utilizar tapabocas en mexico
dieron inicio a un proyecto dedicado a
inocular a todos aquellos que lo deseen
contra el kobe 19 si una vacunación
abierta como parte del plan de
vacunación masiva cuando la tendencia de
contagios en ese país es a la baja
veamos
una estocada final contra el cob y
mayores de 18 años y estar dispuesto a
inocularse esos son los requisitos
necesarios para culminar según el
presidente lópez obrador con la
vacunación en todo el país contra el
coronavirus yo me lo puse con mi
decisión por mí cualquier dije no oit en
ese momento tengo que para colarme la
cuarta para que tenga todo un proyecto
que tan sólo en la ciudad de mexico
habilitó con ese fin unos 187 centros
médicos a decir del director general de
servicios de salud de la ciudad de
mexico la inyección está disponible para
todo aquel que quiera inocularse el
medicamento contra el virus e incluso
extranjeros me parece una excelente
decisión
que hay un mayor número de lugares en
donde uno se puede vacunar
porque porque nos jamás acepta nuestro
domicilio de nuestro trabajo entonces es
muy rápido muy ágil según las
autoridades mexicanas desde hace algunas
semanas los contagios tienden a
disminuir para el arranque del programa
de vacunación se contará con medio
millón de dosis de astrazéneca
y ahora demos un vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con la pandemia
del cob y 19 que están destacadas en
redes comenzamos en paraguay el carnet
de vacunación para el ingreso al país ya
no es obligatorio así lo dio a conocer
la directora de migraciones de ese país
suramericano ángeles arriola quien
indicó que para ingresar a paraguay los
viajeros tienen como alternativa
presentar un test de pcr negativo
realizado máximo 48 horas antes de su
ingreso a suelo paraguayo también el
gobierno de ese país dejó sin efecto el
uso obligatorio del tapabocas
y la ope se advierte que la pandemia
continúa pero deja a cada país su manejo
la organización indicó que cada país
puede declarar el fin de la emergencia
cuando alcance una baja transmisión
comunitaria sin embargo pidió no bajar
la guardia
y por fin el espectáculo continuará el
icónico o carnaval de río de janeiro
regresa después de dos años
interrumpidos por la pandemia el
coronavirus del cob y 19 así se preparan
los cariocas veamos
[Música]
después de dos años de ausencia y
confinamientos el carnaval de río de
janeiro regresa este fin de semana y
promete un frenesí de plumas carrozas y
piernas
momentos juegos fue mucho tiempo
esperando que llegara este día todos
estamos deseando que llegue estamos
cansados
[Música]
quiero que todos se apure está tardando
demasiado la vida se trata de alegría no
de tristezas
no es posible definir lo que sentimos
porque llevamos dos años conteniendo
nuestras soluciones esperando ojalá
estemos bien hidratados y ya que habrá
lágrimas de las pasarelas
envueltos en lentejuelas miles de
bailarines de la ciudad buscan llegar al
sambódromo el icónico lugar del desfile
que el año pasado se convirtió en un
centro de vacunación contra el kobe 19 y
se espera que sea una competencia reñida
entre las escuelas de samba el carnaval
se realiza bajo unas reglas estrictas y
tradicionales ante los jueces cada
escuela tiene hasta 70 minutos para
contar una historia a través de la
música y el baile la ciudad exige que
todos los participantes y asistentes
estén completamente vacunados y no habrá
blocos las grandes fiestas callejeras
que acompañan el desfile después de los
temores de un aumento de coronavirus el
evento se pospuso dos meses este año
luego de su cancelación en 2020 y 2021
cuando la pandemia asoló a brasil el
número total de muertes de país por el
coronavirus es superado sólo por eeuu
hasta aquí comí 19 la semana en américa
siga con nosotros que tenemos mucha más
información
[Música]